in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit. Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 30th on which we commemorate
the Holy Hyromarter Gregory, the illuminator of Greater Armenia.
On the 30th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Hyromarter Gregory,
the Enlightener, Catholicos of Greater Armenia. St. Gregory was born around the year 240.
He was the son of Anak the Parthian, a relative of King Kostrov of Armenia,
whom Anak assassinated on the orders of the Persian king Arteshear.
For this crime, Anak's entire family was put to death with the exception of Gregory
and one of his brothers, who were exiled to Caesarea in Cappadocia as children.
There in Roman territory, Gregory learned of the holy doctrines of the Christians and was baptized.
Tiridatus, one of the sons of Kostrov, also arrived in Caesarea, exiled by the Persian king,
and Gregory entered his service, but without letting him know that Anak was his father.
Later on, Tiridatus was restored to the Armenian throne by the Romans.
In return for a great service he did the Empire.
Far from seeing in this the benevolent hand of the only God who does good to all that he has made,
Tiridatus immediately showed a wild zeal for idle worship and was enraged when Gregory,
who had served him in the hard years of their common exile, refused to deny Christ.
Dispising any thought of obligation toward him, he put Gregory to such a variety of cruel tortures
as only the devil could suggest.
The holy martyr was hung on a frame and scourged for entire days.
His legs were clamped in vices and his bones crushed.
He was made to run with nails driven into the souls of his feet and a bag of burning coals was put over his head
and he suffered so many other torments that even to name them all would be worrisome.
But Gregory stood steadfast, having taken to himself the whole armor of the invincible faith of Christ
and did not seize to give thanks to God for having made him worthy to suffer for his name.
When Tiridatus discovered that Gregory was the son of his father's assassin, his fury redoubled.
And for fifteen years he kept the saint in a deep pit full of reptiles and other venomous creatures
near Mount Ararat, where he was fed secretly by a widow.
After the martyrdom of Saint Ripsimi and her companions, the Lord struck Tiridatus in his wrath.
The king lost his reason and went to live among the swine, going on all fours and knowing at his own flesh.
His sister, Kozruvi Doct, learned in a dream that he could be cured only at the prayer of Saint Gregory.
They brought the athlete of Christ out of his pit, therefore, and were amazed to find him in perfect health and strength.
Gregory cured the king and persuaded him to adhere to the Christian faith in order to save his soul from everlasting punishments more dreadful than any he had suffered as a madman.
With his own hands Tiridatus helped his sister to build a church in honor of Saint Ripsimi and her companions whom he had put to death.
Gregory baptized him in the river Euphrates with his nobles and a great many of his subjects, circa the year 290.
The pagan priests destroyed the idols temples themselves and when Gregory had baptized and laid hands on them, they became priests of God most high.
In a short time there were churches everywhere in Armenia and the land re-echoed the sound of songs and hymns and spiritual songs.
Having spread the peace of Christ throughout Armenia and in the neighboring lands, Gregory withdrew with some disciples to a cave in the wilderness, eating but once in forty days and conversing continuously with God.
To console the faithful, he appointed Aristakis, one of the two sons of his youth, as Katholikos, of greater Armenia.
Aristakis took part in the Council of Nysia in the year 325 and was a worthy successor to his father.
About the year 328, Saint Gregory fell asleep in peace to rejoice everlastingly in the light of the Holy Trinity with whose radiance he had enlightened his people.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.